my name is NaN chanda I'm
editor-in-chief of al global online it
is our pleasure to have in our studios
dr. Carlos Lopez executive director of
the economic commission for africa
welcome to yell thank you it's a great
pleasure to have you in our Studios
especially in this occasion when you are
discussing the issue of African
Development the first question that I
think many of my viewers would like to
ask you is that has aid being a curse
for a figure has ailed helped Africa
just a broad question actually it's a
debate it is quite topical right now
there are number of developments taking
place in the continent and they have
influenced the perception about aid
effectiveness debate and there was a
time where everybody thought that aid
and conditionality associated with aid
were responsible for developments in
Africa and now somehow it's the opposite
people believe that it is not playing
such an important role and most of the
developments are shaped by the fact that
there is an emergence of Africa in terms
of its role on investment trade but also
the interest of other parts of the world
that are not traditional aid donors my
feeling is that this issue of
attribution is really misplaced in the
development debate normally if
development takes place it's always
attributable only to the individuals of
that country now the various factors
that can influence that discussion they
can of course have some degree of
influence but we should not give them
too much weight the most important
element of ownership of development
process that conducts you know any
country to transformation is actually
the individuals of the country itself
yeah I think that I think it's obvious
the question really is whether the aid
has been misspent
with a lack of proper supervision or
control of the how the ada's used has
led to this partial up edge for private
gains and not help the country that
perhaps is one issue it is very clear
that depending on geopolitical interests
Aid has benefited certain types of
policies and depending on the period of
of your analysis you can see the trends
changing like for instance during
structural adjustment programs in Africa
in the 80s and the 90s it was pretty
obvious that aid was very much linked to
a certain type of policies prescriptive
policies reduced policy space in Africa
quite considerably and therefore you
know most of the aid was to produce
liberalisation shrinking of the state
and you name it on the other hand you
can also see that in other moments of
history for certain donors there was a
complicity between eight givers and aid
recipients that could have been
dictators or even you know people that
were more interested in their pockets
and it has not produced really any
poverty reduction or inclusion policies
but more recently you can also say that
people have become much more refined in
the way they deal with aid budgetary
support is one of the tools that is now
very much fashionable in certain
countries and you can see it's also
shaping certain types of outcomes so I
think Aid has played always a role and
continues to play a role but this role
has been shrinking over time precisely
because of the realization somehow that
it is very difficult to make it
completely effective although of course
you know it can also contribute to major
development outcomes yeah Africa is now
suddenly emerging as a
as a continent which sort of holds the
future of the world economy because of
one the population is growing there fast
and these tremendous resources Africa
has 600 million hectares of uncultivated
land so technically theoretically after
you would become the world's breadbasket
so what what are the obstacles in
realizing that potential you know when
people look into China and they say well
China is now becoming such an important
contributor as a poll of growth and its
size in the world economy has expanded
so dramatically that now it's not only
the second largest economy but this
poised maybe to become the first what
people normally don't remember is that
you know China used to have that
position in the past so it's like a
circle that is coming back 180 degrees
well Africa is a bit the same story the
Industrial Revolution in Europe was not
possible without cheap commodities from
Africa and to a large extent we can say
that part of the development that took
place in Latin America in particular was
due to a slave labor from Africa of
course the United States the same so
what what is happening today is somehow
just Africa becoming a bit more
assertive in the use of its own
resources that's one element second is
that the demand now is coming from
different parts of the world so there is
no more this cheap acquisition of
Africans richness so there are
competitors so the commodity prices go
up and as a result Africans get a better
share of the value of their products
although it's still not the full share i
would argue and then the third element
that I think is contributing is what you
mentioned the demographic
dimensions of Africa right now I've
created the middle class a younger
population more urbanized more connected
better educated and as a result we have
internal demand that is quite
substantive and most of our growth is is
basically justified by these two
elements commodity prices and internal
demand so I think those are structural
elements of the current boom that we are
witnessing with the Africa becoming
depending on how you want to cut it
either the region with the fastest
growth or the second if you divide Asia
in blocks and you you compare it with
Southeast Asia yeah also I think the
point you made about the rise of the
kind of villagers rise the middle class
and middle class basically means an
educated class with aspiration and the
respiration also I think transfers into
demand for good governance and that I
think is perhaps is one of the major
abstracting to growth is lack of
governance in many countries absolutely
and you see we have in Africa an index
that has been developed by a
philanthropic foundation mo ibrahim
foundation that measures governance
progress it's a very thorough index with
quite a large number of indicators in a
very thorough methodology and what you
can see is that you know the number of
countries progressing on economic and
political governance is quite
significant and in fact the majority of
Africans today in fact more than
two-thirds of the Africans today live in
a better governed country than just ten
years ago so there is progress but this
being said of course institutions are
you
hard to build this doesn't happen
overnight you know take the example of
corruption and you know accusations that
Africa is corrupt here and there I mean
of course it is true we know that
corruption is not an African phenomena
but what is interesting is what type of
corruption are we talking about the
corruption that you'll find in Africa in
most of the cases is the corruption that
is associated with weak institutions
institutions that are not yet with a
level of sophistication that makes the
rulers if you want accountable you know
it goes all the way from the way you tax
people and the fiscal authorities to the
way the president runs the country so
you have this weakness that is intrinsic
to the fact that we are dealing with
realities that have not yet developed
the battery of regulations methods
processes and and more importantly
counter powers that will allow for more
transparency and then a better
governance but this type of corruption
is not the most important corruption
taking place in Africa the most
important corruption is mispricing by
mineral companies it's illicit financial
flows and capital flight provoked most
of the times by the fact that there is
an exploitation of African natural
resources and this is not so much talked
about and that is the big money because
if you just look into the transaction
and financial flows between African the
rest of the world it's very easy to
detect that there is something missing
in between not of rounding errors there
yes so so the question then is the so
far Natural Resources has been a sort of
prime mover for economic development but
mining oil and gas or mineral resources
or forest product does not really create
jobs so what are the industry you can
see that could develop in Africa they're
using its resources but producing job
you are absolutely right in fact you
know the old mineral and extractive
industry in the continent employs about
1% of the labor force so it's quite
negligible although it's quite rich in
terms of exports from the continent and
also its contribution to the size of our
economic activity Africans continue to
be poor mostly because they are in the
primary sector about sixty percent the
productivity is very low it's the lowest
in the world you know 1.5 tonnes per
hectare more or less it has not moved
for the last 20 years despite a lot of
money being put by aid and other
contributions from public funds it has
not changed and of course the fact that
our industries have been under attack we
are not in a level playing field value
chains have become very complex Africans
don't dominate trade negotiations or
they'd rather suffer from it and as a
result we have an environment that is
not favorable including you know
ingredients that make manufacturing
possible such as infrastructure energy
all the enablers including financial
ones I'm not there therefore we have an
industrial sector that has been
shrinking and part of this growth has
been provoked by an explosion of
services but services that are mostly
informal also don't create modern jobs
so all of these points in the direction
that we have a major problem of
employment so here you are you have six
percent growth as it is predicted for
this year average for the continent but
you don't create jobs because the
structure of the employment somebody
mentioned forty percent of the people
are I really don't like to coat
employment figures for the entire
continent because the level
of statistical quality is so poor that
it will be really as ardyss to give
averages unemployment for the continent
even for GDP we know the problems that
exist when countries do rebasing
normally they double their size because
there is a huge underestimation of
Africa's GDP because of informal
activities but at least we know from
financial transactions and the structure
of the financial sector and you know the
type of monetary instruments that you
have you are you can guess better but
unemployment is really quite as orders
because most of the activities are not
formal jobs and it is very difficult to
know whether people have occupations but
it is true that the majority of the
population in the continent living in
urban areas is not employed so that much
we know and of course there are a couple
of countries that have better statistics
and then this becomes more tangible and
it confirms the trend but what I think
is important for us to bear in mind is
that unemployment Africans are not going
to make it with these poor services that
are basically informal sector related or
a very low productivity in agriculture
because it does move the value chain
it's not in agro-processing so we really
have to create industrial capabilities
and this is what we are arguing that
industrialization in Africa is not only
possible but desirable and also that it
has to be a different industrialization
from what others have done dinner lean
one way well we cannot do import
substitution like the Latin Americans
did when they industrialize of course we
are even further away from the European
Industrial Revolution we cannot even
copy ubaldo it's from a timeline closer
the Southeast Asia export driven model
because all of these niches are more or
less occupied we are late
but not only we are late comers but the
environment and the context have
actually become much more difficult than
when those that I just quoted did it for
instance you have much more regulation
on trade you have now very complex value
chain segmentation of industrial
production intellectual property has
become the most valued element of the of
the of the equation you of course have
the the financial systems sophisticated
in terms of transactions access to
equity premium insurances and then you
name it so for all those reasons
Africans cannot just do what others did
so how are they going to make it in
terms of industrialization well I like
to argue through three very important
entry points the first one we have a
certain number of commodities that we
have a controlling stake in the global
market we need a better bargain and and
and i think Africans have to position
themselves to make sure that they move
along the value chain maybe not
completely but they have to find ways of
taking advantage of the faxing them to
some exactly exactly so you are talking
about some minerals from both soft and
hard commodities it works as well for
coffee as it works for Colton the second
is that I think it is very important for
us to leapfrog technologically we can
offer a cleaner industrialization than
all the others because you know the
technologies are available now we are
not married to any technological plan
west coast exactly we we can do it
differently and we have a huge potential
on renewable energy that can you know
propel this move and the third we have
to look into our own pockets for that we
need regional integration into Africa
drain boosters are not going to ask you
that that to have an integrated
continent-wide market
you don't have to think of export
substitution Export Promotion I think
you can do it inside we have a huge room
to occupy for the moment because you
know Africa continues to import yogurt
toothpaste you know we have so much that
you can do just you know by making sure
that you boost in traffic a trade and
the the potential is not only enormous
for Africa but it's also attractive for
foreign investors because they can see
Africa as a market where they can
position themselves grow a middle class
and of course you know it's going to be
the largest labor force by 2040 I think
we have argued yes I think it's going to
be important that industrialization in
Africa and the debate about industrial
policy is done in a way that is not pure
imitating of other realities but rather
organic and responding to these
imperatives I just mentioned the one
role that has been played in african
development is the media communication
so cell phone has been a factor of
promoting a lot of services right
absolutely in fact Africa is more cell
phones than india more cell phones there
Europe and more cell phones than the
u.s. internet penetration is larger than
India and if you look into the
innovation within telecom sector in
Africa everybody agrees that it has been
quite rapid and actually surprising
Africa as health of the world's mobile
banking transactions half and you know
you would not have expected that the
continent with the purists you know sort
of education patterns different exactly
so I think you know it's very clear that
you you you can only do it with certain
types of technologies sometimes because
you use frugal technology or frugal
innovation sometimes it's because you
know the the
simplicity of the the technological sort
of media that you you are using like
cell phones or other devices make it
possible because they are very mobile
they are very easy to absorb and I think
Africans may surprise many by being a
center of innovation in areas such as
the IT and I think this is very much the
demonstration that I think we should use
also for energy Africans do not need to
have solutions for their electricity
deficit that are imitating the
investments of other regions of the
world we can go very much into renewable
we can go to off-grid solutions there
are plenty of opportunities that now are
mastered technologically that Africa can
be the pioneer or can be at least the
terrain where this is expanded in in
scale that is excellent and with that
positive not developers thank you so
much for speaking with thank you there's
been a pleasure